good morning angels reboot so guys if
you watched our Junko Cruz upload that
we put up a little bit ago there's a
crazy wildfire really close to us it
started less than 10 miles away right
now it's like it smells like the fires
pretty bad a friend of ours had to get
mandatorily evacuated I'm sure other
friends of ours who live near there have
been evacuated to you we are gonna just
shoot this really quick then we're gonna
take off for the day cause it probably
seems like the best safety bed and we're
probably next in line but if we fall
behind on anything like an El Camino
review you know why anywho let's watch
this don't call me angel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
really not supposed to be touching
things in here supposed to be
[Music]
[Music]
so we can just take with everyone all
right
[Music]
is this like a pro vote for this album
that song is that canon are these
characters that release the song
existing movie or is movie a part of the
songs world a lot of whole new things in
this trailer you get a little bit more
personality from the Bosley characters
of Patrick Stewart and Elizabeth Banks
I'm sure it will be fine Charlie's
Angels so I'm not like you feel Steven
to be like really roar from the last
trailer for some reason it's not like
they turn them all on the guy's mad
about what this is Charlie's Angels guys
does this movie look great to me but I'm
sure it'll be passable entertainment its
Charlie's Angels it doesn't look like
it's taking itself super serious the
thing that looks like it'll be a bit of
an issue is where's this tonally trying
to meet because it looks like it's
trying to be a little bit more of that
the cool kind of Mission Impossible spy
movies that are more grounded but then
there's sides where it looks like
they're trying to be the cheesy sexy
can't be Charlie's Angels element and
then I don't like slice it together and
I don't think you can do that then again
I'm the guy who likes Charlie's Angels
full throttle which is not known if you
do but I like weird cheesy not well made
Charlie's Angels stuff hot girls kicking
ass and mean smart
that's all Charlie's Angels needs to be
and it's nice to have some cool action I
don't know if this trailer is gonna win
over any new people we'd like the first
trailer this trailer is just his surface
suppose the last one came watching
movies as long as it's not boring I'm
okay look like that's literally my my
baseline criteria for this film as long
as it's not boring yeah basically I mean
I I'm not a huge fan of these trailers
as specially as they keep dropping
mainly because yeah I can't really get
for the tone other than a general I
don't know this movie seems to think
that it's really a badass and it seems
to be really enjoying its own vibe but
these trailers are also cut so fast and
they're cramming kind of the same images
in a different medley each time it just
seems like it thinks it's so cool and
I'm waiting to see if it's that cool and
like I like everybody involved
so like I'm hoping that the movie itself
ultimately winds up being a good time
but you know yeah I'm not really getting
a great deal from these trailers other
than how cool the movie thinks it is
there's a lot they have to sell a song
and in these trailers they have to saw
us on reboot different style different
tones new cast of characters and new
takes on the on the just and the three
angels and then the new Bosley's there's
a lot they're trying to sell us on to
the treatment it's the time span and
they're trying to sell us an album at
the same time
literally a scene from the music video
is so confusing
yeah so the end of the music video
they're trying to like really sell a
whole package here I really think that
with the whole cast that they have
assembled I imagine that we're gonna
walk away going everyone was very
charming really committed and there's
great chemistry for a movie called
Charlie's Angels what matters most is
that those three fleas have a great
rapport and that they make us laugh and
that we're entertained the whole time
and I just think they're gonna deliver
that but they're gonna dial back all the
crazy bikini shots that new well yeah
this is the closet it's like it's either
badass or like very girly and both of
those things video but yeah these
trailers again at least to me are like
you sliced so quickly and none of them
has bothered to focus on something
different about the movies I'm kind of
taking him in this advertising going
cool every movie will ultimately have a
larger demographic of male or female
whether that's intentional or not and I
think would make Gees Charlie's Angels
that had more of a male audience
demographic because it was like
get these hot girls like the hole toes
like googly and stuff and then here they
seem to have with Elizabeth Banks
humming it I think this can lend itself
to a more female demographic yeah for
sure and I think that's a good idea I
think that's the point of what they're
trying to do with this this one around
but at the same time it's like does that
mean it's gonna be a good movie
automatically no I don't have no idea
it'll be fine what do you want it from I
don't want visitor into it ghostbusters
the situation that's like we saw it I
was like it was funny yeah I had a good
time and then literally like when the
movie circles we run in I just was like
crapping on it and it like does their
gossip talking happening it strange guys
know it comes from a source material
even though even that source material
isn't the most risk that source material
isn't the most risk there is an element
of camp to the source material in and of
itself and so yeah I think the
circumstances are decent and I didn't
see pitch perfect 3 but that seemed to
be Elizabeth Banks jumping up a caliber
into more action comedy territory so
she's clearly taking another step here
and that's the main thing I want is just
an actual breathable taste of yeah
movies gonna be like cuz I'm actually
really curious and I feel like most of
the point of all these trailers has been
music video yeah well go sillas I gotta
buy that album old school promotion I
don't gotta make sure they make that
money back on all that music license
that's a good music video guys well what
do you think of Charlie's Angels
do you hate this comment below do you
love it comment below
creating here thinking that there's no
reason to get pissed comment below
is it just the little circle we run in
probably you guys should subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell for at the supper let's see a
patient add a shout out to a lovely
woman named
Coria Huntley Victoria listen my dear I
gotta say I know you're engaged right
now and everything and I'm sure that you
will live happily ever after with your
man the worst case scenario if need be
if it doesn't pan out you know what you
could always do you could always become
one of these sexy angels after seeing a
couple of cosplay photos clearly you are
a woman for the job don't worry if you
can't have a happily ever after you got
it even more bitchin back-up plan where
a man named Charlie will ruin your life
send you out on all kinds of missions so
either way you got a man destroying you
internally mm-hmm that's what the real
plot line ought to be just go up to the
top take Charlie out and assume
leadership for yourself that's what
feminism is about Victoria Huntley's
angel don't forget it boom bah it's like
you're a teen shout out we're try